[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another episode of
WhatsApp Prof
hello Walter I'm Martin are you doing
well yes thank you yeah so your title is
a little bit strange today
yes why should we only speak about
adults yeah little children
well it will be interesting to find out
what it's all about but let's first open
with a word of Prayer
my heavenly father thank you once again
we are here
to bring a message to people that we
believe are from you so please enlighten
our minds and help us to bring this
message over in Jesus name amen amen
we're talking about the seriousness of
the times we are living in
and we're also talking about dangers
that face God's people
preparations that need to be made
and so I thought we could talk about
some things that are interesting in the
Bible
and some lessons that we can learn
from Israel about the period just before
they went into Canaan because we're
living in the antidype we're exactly
there we're just waiting to cross the
Jordan yes
so the title is little children
and I was doing a little bit of studying
and reading
and you know when Paul says when I was a
child I thought like a child
Etc
but now I'm an adult
and then uh
John and his letters refers to the
congregation as little children yes
and they don't seem to gel right
so what does it mean we need to grow up
we need to be adults so maybe the little
children has a different connotation
maybe we should look a little bit deeper
what does it mean
when you are referred to as a little
child you know we also have that song I
will always be a child in your eyes yeah
yeah and I always think to myself you
know don't we need to be adults in the
time that we live in don't we need to be
circumspect and be able to discern what
is right and what is wrong so what does
it mean to be a little child and why
does he refer to them as little children
that will be interesting yeah so I had a
look at it and I thought oh I'm gonna
put in little children and see what
comes up in the search engine
and of course there are other terms like
little child yeah and so we'll we'll
have a look at them
so if you do a search in the King James
version you find 20 verses that use the
term little children
and the first one here that uh comes to
to view is Matthew 18 verse 3. and this
is Jesus speaking
and he said verily I say unto you except
you be converted and become as Little
Children You shall not enter into the
kingdom of heaven and I thought whoa
that's a serious verse
that is one of the most serious verses
in in the Bible because if you don't
adhere to this you won't enter heaven
correct and that is terrible now in
order to be able to be converted you
need to have the capacity to make a
decision
and that's a that's an adult concept
yes but then he comes and he says and
become as little children and if you
don't you won't enter into into heaven
so it must be very important
so surely it can't mean that you give up
your decision-making capacity
and your adult intuitions
Etc and you it must mean something else
so what is so important about becoming
as a little child
and uh when they brought the little
children to him
they were very welcome
and the disciples tried to prevent it
and Jesus rebuked them and said suffer
not the little children to come unto me
bring them to me and he laid hands and
he said forbid them not
and if you read in the spirit of
Prophecy you have these stories about
the children laughing
Etc and the Pharisees were so
disgruntled about it
so interesting story so why must we
become like a little child what is the
aspect that God is talking about here
so these are parallel texts in Mark of
course and Simon Luke
and then
in John 13 33 Jesus addresses them as
little children
and he says yet a little while I am with
you you shall seek me and as I said unto
the Jews whether I go you cannot come so
now I say unto you so he addressed the
disciples as little children yes
now if you read in the letters of the of
the Apostles and of Paul
you get the same term my little children
of whom I travail in birth again until
Christ be formed in you
oh John he uses the term a lot
in his in his Epistles my little
children these things write down unto
you that you sin not and if any man sin
we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous
and here again in verse 12 I write unto
you little children because your sins
are forgiven you for his name's sake
and 1 John 2 verse 13 he uses the term
again because you have known the father
little children
and then in 1 John 2 Verse 18 Little
Children it is the last time it seems he
uses the term a lot right yeah it seems
like any time he addresses
the people at the churches they've
called little children and he says and
now little children abide in him that
when he shall appear we may have
confidence and not be ashamed before him
at his coming
or 1 John 3 verse 7 little children let
no man deceive you he that doeth the
righteousness is righteous even as he is
righteous these are important verses and
they're always addressed to the little
children in the church yeah
now surely that's not literal right
because you have to be converted you
have to make very deep decisions you
have to discern it's the last time you
have to prevent deception so you have to
study so it's not obviously not talking
to the kids right
my little children let us not love in
word neither in tongue but indeed and in
truth
and then
1 John 4 verse 4 ye are of God little
children that have overcome them because
greater is he that is in you
than he that is in the world little
children keep yourself from Idols so I
must have taken it pretty serious when
Jesus said
if you don't become like a little child
you can't enter into heaven right true
and then he has all of these adult
statements that tell you how you must be
yeah you must be able to discern you
must be able to do all of these things
but you have to be a little child or
else you're not going to go in
looks like a little bit of a
contradiction in terms yes
what about the term little child
well there are a number of verses in
that aziah is a literal little child
that will lead uh you know the lion and
the coffin the young will lie together
and a little child shall lead them
that's literal
or when Jesus called the little child
and set them in their midst
that's a literal little child
whosoever therefore shall humble himself
as this little child the same is
greatest in the kingdom of heaven and
who shall receive one such little child
in my name receiveth me
that one all right that's a that could
be more than one connotation right so if
you are new to the truth
aren't you a little child in the faith
exactly that is what Paul was referring
to as well okay he was on milk now
Martin if you are born again are you
born an adult or you're born a child
that's a very good one he'd born a child
okay so spiritually speaking you can be
a little child yes
but physically speaking you can be an
adult yes
and you have to receive a little child
in the Name of Christ
so a newly converted born-again
Christian is a little child that's it
just be treated as such now when when
John was speaking to new believers they
were all little children that's it now
they had received some information that
made a decision they have come into the
church
and now they were being nurtured by word
and by example and by all of the things
that the disciples did
and again you have this statement in
Luke verily I say unto you whoever shall
not receive the kingdom of God as a
little child shall in no wise enter
their Inn so it's a very very serious
issue
and Luke 9 verse 48 basically repeats
that so my question is what do little
children do
I think they believe right they trust
and believe so you can tell them about
the tooth fairy and they'll believe it
and they'll trust you when you stand on
the side of a swimming pool and then
you're inside and you say to them jump
they jump they don't mind everything and
the same with so they believe so unless
you believe
you cannot please God faith so you have
to be in faith like a little child right
doesn't Hebrews say that exactly without
faith it is impossible to please him
yeah and what kind of Faith must you
have a little child you must have the
faith of a little child
Jesus said unto him if thou can't
believe this is Mark 9 23 all things are
possible to him that believeth and
straightway the father of the child
cried out and said with tears Lord I
believe help thou mind unbelief
so our problem is our unbelief
and there are so many that suffer from
unbelief right
so we have to believe we have to believe
like a little child like Hebrews 11 6 we
must believe
and we must believe that God exists and
that is a rewarder of them that
diligently seek him so faith
is something that is akin to a little
child that's it you know what I think of
the previous episode that we did on the
creation
and if you believe like a child you you
will believe what God says you will
believe what God said it's like your
doesn't the Bible call him your father
that's it so he's telling you where you
come from Iran is not telling you that
you were caught in the mountain and they
dropped your tail off and then you mean
became a human being right yes he's not
lying to us no because God is not a man
that he should lie that's wonderful and
the child
doesn't even know if his father is lying
to him because he believes him he
believes him and that's how you should
believe because our father can't lie
okay so it's very important
that we believe
many say that all we have to do is
believe
it's always the tongue-in-cheeks
but they make the service of Christ all
together too superficial
they are satisfied with a nominal belief
in Christ but it is not enough to merely
assert that Jesus is the son of God we
must abide in him as the branch abides
in the vine we must have an experimental
Faith a faith that works by love and
purifies the soul
then we have evidence that we bear fruit
to the glory of God
what is it to bear fruit to the glory of
God
it is to manifest the love of Jesus in
our daily life to be kind courteous
forbearing to those around us and to try
to lead them to the savior
so
believing is one thing
and acting on that faith is another
thing right that's so true I mean so
you're now you believe it doesn't get
left there no it has to have fruits
there's a whole string of things it has
to follow that to show that it's
actually true belief otherwise otherwise
if you've got a fact believe right
because you really believe what God says
then you have to transform your life I
think that's very important and the work
of perfecting the soul through obedience
to All God's requirements must be
constantly going on in our lives to how
many of his requirements all
why are we so selective
I don't know that's an excellent
question do you know the answer no
if we regard iniquity in our hearts the
Lord will not hear us will you open the
door of the heart and let the light of
Heaven in sounds harsh but he will not
hear us if we regard iniquity but I
think I might have an answer to that
question earlier I think we've become
teenagers we're not little children
anymore that's why we better revert to
little children in faith and says God
says so
therefore I believe it there's that song
God said it and I believe it and that's
yes and that settles it and that settles
it for me that's the way it is
we have to know what we believe and why
we believe it and that is a very
important point for the time we are
living in because we will be challenged
on every single point true
particularly all those points which
point out a path of obedience that
others have rejected and Satan knows the
portions that you have that has to be
worked on so you also pay attention on
Those portions to help you you not to
adhere as much as you should
all right so if we want to believe
Martin in the times that we are living
in then we must be able to know what is
True Religion and what is false religion
aren't we warned about false religion
all the time yes be careful not to be
deceived that will be something that's
false all right
so how do you discern True Religion
well here's a quote from councils to
parents teachers and students
Christ is the center of all true
Doctrine
now the Pope says Doctrine is not
important no but the Bible says take
heed of the doctrine so one of the two
is lying either the Bible or the Pope I
I don't think it's too difficult to
figure that one out right
all true religion is found in his word
and in nature
he's the one in whom our hopes of
eternal life are centered and the
teacher who learns from him finds a safe
Anchorage so two aspects
all true religion is christ-centered
yeah and you can find it in the word and
you can find it in nature
depends on how you read nature can can
you read the word falsely yes aren't
they teach us falsely so called
absolutely and their science falsely so
called as well oh so can you read nature
incorrectly as well exactly
in other words you have to pour nature
through the filter of the word
and what be exactly I think that's what
we've tried to do in the previous
episodes hopefully that people have seen
because that brings you closer to your
creator that's really interesting if you
take uh you know
indigenous people that have let's say
not had the privilege of Education let's
say tribes in in Jungle areas
they all believe in God because they
read them in nature they might not
understand him they might have the wrong
concept of him but they all believe in
God that's it it's only when they become
educated that they lose their faith in
God yeah that's rather sad right
and there's the second aspect true
religion is nothing short of Conformity
to the will of God
oh they it's that's a big troubling
right it's putting it straight so
if you do not conform to the will of God
are you practicing a false religion or
are you faking your religion exactly
that's the only way you only have two
ways here it's either false or true and
if it was to be true you have to conform
to the world all right so unless you
become as a little child you will by no
means enter into heaven
now a little child doesn't always want
to obey but if you are Stern enough he
he will obey eventually
right yes and obedience to all things
that he has commanded and in return it
gives us spiritual life imputes to us
the righteousness of Christ and promotes
the healthful and happy exercise of the
best faculties of the mind and heart
infinite riches the glory and
blessedness of eternal life are bestowed
upon us on conditions so simple
as to bring the Priceless gift within
the reach of the poorest and most sinful
we have only to obey and believe
that's activities
in Jesus but to trust and Obey but it's
in two legs always two legs why is it
that everybody wants to hobble on one
yeah it's always a problem
and his Commandments are not Grievous
obedience to his requirements is
essential to our happiness even in this
life all right so let's just make it
quite clear again
if you want to have True Religion
you can only see it in the fruits
that's why Jesus says words are easy you
might be able to say lots of things that
stand in the Bible but if the fruits are
not there then you are practicing a
false religion or faking it or fooling
yourself yeah true religion is not an
experiment
it's an actual imitation of Christ
so these are powerful statements aren't
they it's absolutely beautiful
so
one like you said earlier if you're
Faking It I'm sorry what some time or
another it's gonna catch you out or
catch up to you at the latest
persecution will reveal it oh definitely
yes
God keeps a personal account with every
man testing him by the Practical results
of his work soon will be heard the call
give an account of thy stewardship
oh in that time well soon was soon then
so soon must be sooner now definitely
well after all the last days latter days
and all of those that we've mentioned
I'm sure by now people can realize at
what time we are soon is
around the corner so what's our Point
here a point is
preparation for the final crisis and
preparation for going into Canaan we
have to practice True Religion
and if we haven't been doing it and if
we've been holding back on something
it's better it's it's certainly time for
a little bit of introspection Now isn't
it definitely all right so true religion
is embodied in the word of God that's a
Protestant principle
to date
True Religion I mean we did talk about
all those revivals or often based on
nothing but emotion and that's where the
big problem lies and if the spirit
doesn't take you to the word then there
is no light in that spirit
and it consists in being under the
guidance of the Holy One in thought word
and deed but that thought word and deed
must be a nominee with the word yes
so he who is the way the truth and the
life takes the humble Earnest
wholehearted seeker and says follow me
he leads him in the narrow way to
Holiness and heaven and all who decide
to follow the lord fully
will be led in the Royal path and the
Royal path is obviously the narrow one
that's it not the easy one no
and why is that necessary
well you have to be tasted and tried to
find out if you are living a True
Religion yeah is it genuine or is it a
flesh in the pan
did you hear the word and did it fall
onto Stony ground or did it fall into
good soil
and if it happened to fall in not such a
it's not the end of the world you can do
some plowing that's what exactly I'm so
glad you mentioned that because if you
know that you've been the soil that the
sower sowed unto you actually can decide
what type of soil you are yes and if you
it's your choice so if I want to be the
one where the Thorns took everything
away it was a choice yes and if you're
easily slighted and turn away so you can
work on it wasn't Jesus constantly
slighted yeah did he turn away no no
when the disciples constantly slighted
so it's it's not an easy part but it's
essential because it has to try you
so what if there's True Religion there
must be false religion right yes
unfortunately okay so what is false
religion
this compromise between paganism and
Christianity resulted in the development
of the man of sin foretold in Prophecy
as opposing and exalting himself above
God that gigantic system of false
religion
is a masterpiece of Satan's power a
monument to his efforts to seat himself
upon the throne to rule the Earth
according to his will
so what is false religion it's paganism
and Christianity mingled yeah
it's not a religious it is a religion
but it is a masterpiece
of his power yeah
so we have to be very careful of any
mixing of paganism and Christianity and
it's so important because that usually
happens when you lower your standard or
you want to be accepted or anything like
that that's usually when a pagan thing
Creeps in okay that statement came from
the great controversy Christ has
declared to Heaven and Earth past one
jot or one Tittle shall in no wise pass
from the law till all be fulfilled
the truth of God's word alone is
permanent and abiding the loyal subjects
of God's kingdom will not be found
trampling upon his law
pronounced by inspiration to be holy and
just and good every false religion
is of Satan's originating
hmm and the warning must be given to the
world why do men continue so blindly and
unbelief when the word of God is so
plain and unmistakable
when the Judgment self sit and the books
are opened what excuse will they give
for taking sides when the with the first
great Rebel thus making the word of God
of none effect in their lives
God's wisdom and truthfulness are
changeless and in that great day when
sentences executed against the despisers
of his law
the Cross of Christ would show that he
is a god of love in thus executing
judgment
those who refuse to obey his Lord during
probationary time could not with safety
be received into his kingdom for they
would labor as earnestly and as
zealously against the law of his
government as did the first apostate
there would be a second rebellion in
heaven
now modern people say we are not under
the law constantly they say that we've
dealt with that many many times do we
thereby make void the law God forbid we
uphold the law so but the point is if
you don't want to obey the law You're
Not Safe in heaven okay so but what you
just mentioned
that falls under false religion yes and
that's a problem because
there's so many people caught up in that
all right now in The ecumenical movement
do they really want to hear the law or
do they adhere to that tradition
tradition so it's false religion it's a
false religion can you have anything to
do with it no yes you can point it out
yes but then you can you then say okay
let's have Fellowship together no
because you are mixing
paganism and Christianity Christianity
and true Christianity
so every false religion is of Satan's
originating and the warning must be
given to the world the truth of God's
word alone is permanent and eternal we
read that before
but why is it so important because you
know the law is Holy just and good
so we have to warn the world you have to
warn the world but the problem is the
world doesn't want to hear this but
whether they're here or whether they
forbear
ezekiel's is quite Plain on the issue if
you want the wicked man and he turns
from his ways then you have done your
job if he doesn't turn from his ways
it's on his head but if you do not warn
him it's on your head and that is what
so this means if you are
following the True Religion you've got a
job you've got to warn and it's quite
clear in the Bible to the law and to the
testimony if they don't speak according
to that word they have no light in them
so I cannot worship together with them
I can be friends I can admonish but
that's where it has to stop but what is
a friend you said you can have
friendship all right but what is the
friend a friend is someone who cares
about you and cares about your
who cares about your eternal life who
cares about your needs who cares about
all of those things
but you know I had a situation where a
man came to me and he said but you know
we've always been friends yes
but I don't believe that Jesus is God
so you believe that Jesus is God so
you know we just differ on that point
why can't we worship together so I said
because you have a different God
your God and my God are different my God
is embodied in Jesus Christ in My
Religion Jesus Is God so when I worship
I worship from that principle that's it
but you do not worship from that
principle and therefore we cannot
worship together we might be able to
play golf together
but if I were a golf player which I'm
not
I understand so the thing is once it's
in a religious setting
friendship is a problem
can I for example partake in a mass no
that's not at all that's partaking in
idolatry so to do things together with
other religious people or religions
cannot be based on a friendship
it's hard all right let's let's put it
another way let's say you're a Sabbath
keeper
and they tell you that they want to do
this that and the other and you must
give up your Sabbath then you say no I
won't then they say but you know you're
not a team player you're supposed to
come and do this with us
if it if it works on that level why not
on the economical level as well they
know that Adventists or Sabbath Keepers
therefore they distantiate themselves
from any form of worship that doesn't
include obedience to the law that's I
would say that's how it should be right
exactly in my opinion here's another
statement which says false religions
which are legion so there are many of
them
must be exposed and cast out of their
hearts that they may have the truth in
contradiction to error you must expose
it
you know people say why are you doing
this why are you talking about all of
these things you're always negative yeah
well false religion happens to be
negative and it must be exposed
unfortunately it's negative towards True
Religion and it's negative towards your
Eternal well-being and life that's it so
it might seem and it might be the the
more uh fashionable one or the easy
going one and the nice one that
everybody is just having a jaw but that
doesn't you have to show the error
so there will be one continual contest
if the infatuation of false theories and
false religion is discarded
and the infatuated idolators lay down
their arms and acknowledge the truth as
it is in Jesus
the people must know what is truth
but the abundance of money devoted to
one section means nothing else than
deprivation of means to make even a
beginning in another section so we have
to be very circumspect we have to be
adults but we have to be little children
in our faith that's it now Martin I
believe there are only four religious
systems in the world
one of which is the truth and the other
three are false
that's quite a bold statement to make
because they are legion
but they only fall into three categories
the false religions as far as I'm
concerned see it comes back to this only
one way one way there's not many ways no
so the truth must be centered in Jesus
Christ and his word and the false
religious systems fall into
categories Dragon Beast and false
prophet religions because that's what
the Bible says yeah
so what is a dragon religion what is a
beast religion and what is the false
prophet religion we need to look at that
right
Revelation 16 verse 13 says on I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs come
out of the mouth of the dragon out of
the mouth of the Beast and out of the
mouth of the false prophet those are the
three categories where the unclean
spirits work yeah
so if you can recognize a dragon
religion
if you can recognize the Beast religion
and if you're going to recognize the
false prophet religion
then you should be okay and your word
the word is the falter and the law
exactly
of the three I would say uh the tricky
one is the false prophets because that
one uh is sneaky yes okay
there's another verse in verse 19 and
the great City it's Babylon
was divided into three parts and since
Babylon comprises all religions it seems
that there are only three parts to that
Babylon that's true and the cities of
the Nations felt and great Babylon came
to the remembrance before God to give
unto her the cup of the wine of the
fierceness of his wrath isn't it
important to warn the Babylonians
exactly and then you have to define the
Babylonians you can't one without
defining we've said that many times
all right you're not fighting alone in
this because we read here that God is
drawing those who listen to conscience
take counsel with right reason and with
God and surrender their world their
entire prospects with the whole heart to
God it is then and only then that the
human agents learns how Wayward is the
heart and how unwilling to give up all
for Jesus
so button is another point if you are
not willing to give up all
it's all not
so so the Rich Young Ruler was required
to give up all that's it and he didn't
realize that if he gives up all the
action he gains all this doesn't mean
you give up literally
physical all it means
everything you might actually have to
give up physically or only to get it
back again it might include that yes
because nobody was left father or mother
for my name's sake will not receive in
this world and in the next
and seek ye first the kingdom of God and
all these things so isn't that what a
little child believes exactly if you are
if you're a good little boy then you're
going to get this
that's true you get rewarded yes
but if they walk in the light well they
have the light to subdue selfishness and
expel it from the soul truth has the
ascendancy
there's a sense of spiritual Freedom
they rejoice in the Glorious Liberty of
the Sons and Daughters of God
and now opposition has to be encountered
if you accept the truth you're going to
tug on the chain
that binds you to Satan's Chariot and he
is going to mess with you yeah
in the world they were gliding along
peaceably but now they have to stem the
current of popular opinion
as they turn from the maxines and
customs of popular professors of
religion the conflict begins in Earnest
they must contend for the faith once
delivered to the Saints but if you if
you are not in the spiritual war
how can you become a hardened Soldier I
mean a fifth Soldier to fight the battle
and you see that's where I think
sometimes the problem comes in a lot of
people don't want conflict or they don't
want to stand out so now you've come to
The ecumenical uh Gatherings or
movements or anything that's like that
and
you blend in you can't blend in because
you have to tug on the Chain so the
conflict begins they must contend for
this Faith or be carried away
from the light away from the truth into
air and darkness to final rune what is
it that causes this contention it is the
Collision of error against truth
the Tyrant is seeking to oppress man's
conscience that Christ has made free
persecution will come more definitely
and decidedly upon the people of God
because The Godly are seeking for
uprightness and holiness
and the disobedient are in sin
how can something that feels so good be
wrong I just heard that the other day
again that's it
and I also heard just the other day will
God condemn this love yeah don't confuse
love with con infatuation
you know we've spoken of this before but
the definition of Love according to the
Bible and according to Hollywood is like
the East is from the west but
unfortunately the world is conditioned
with the Hollywood love yes
the sin loving do not choose the way of
God and the obedient in their character
and course of action or a constant
rebuke to the sinful
when the truth finds access to the heart
it must fight every inch of the way it
is a battle and there's no way getting
rounded you cannot sugar coat this one
this is the way it is and if you're not
prepared to fight this battle
well then you can't get to the top of
the mountain unfortunately that's we've
read that before the Believers in the
truth or guarded jealously as the heart
of God in the fierce conflict before us
mind with mind truth and collision with
error principle with principle this
world will witness scenes that are
intensely interesting of immense
importance
are we are we in that time
definitely are we seeing scenes that
Boggle the mind yeah more and more and
many even of of those that were not into
religion or seeing that something is
wrong yes isn't it now necessary that we
speak it's now or never in many churches
the truth will be sacrificed and error
presented in its place
those who cease to occupy the elevated
position as Watchmen receiving the word
from God and giving the warning to the
people are not aware that they are
arranging themselves under the Black
Banner of the power of Darkness with the
enemies of God and the truth save you do
not
resist with every fiber of your being
and preach the truth in opposition to
error you're going to be swept away well
if we have
followed what was said here earlier
those who cease to occupy the elevated
position as Watchmen so if we decide to
get off the wall
what's going to happen to us you will be
in trouble the people receive the words
from their lips and in turn repeat the
same error to those brought in
connection with them
thus the wine of Babylon is received and
All Nations become drunken with the
spiritual poison we see that those who
will not receive the truth are preparing
to resist its influence they refuse to
be recast in faith and character they
are unwilling to be remodeled in the
image of Christ's character but if you
bring the truth and people resisted and
refused to accept it
there's no point and you can get
disheartened but
God says he will help you to change your
character but you must be willing you
must be willing and that's the thing
that comes into the all you must be
willing to in all aspects let him change
what is needed yes and I say that's why
it's given you and me wives right
for sure make sure we remember
okay let's have a look at the typology
and it's it's a well-known typology but
I believe it's so important for the time
we are living in
because this just happened before they
went into Canaan the Israelites yeah and
this is so I love
you know I didn't know anything about
type and anti-type before I became an
Adventist and through a lot of your
lectures and all of this studying the
spirit of Prophecy the bible really
opens up to you yes once you start
understanding this and so let's have a
look at some of the points and see if we
can glean some something interesting
just looking at the story of balak the
moabite king who wanted to curse Israel
and the false prophet Balaam
who actually was used by God as a true
prophet
[Laughter]
what do these names mean balac means
waster
so he wants to waste God's people
and Balaam means not of the people
hmm button so if somebody is not of the
people and is trying to convince you to
do something
that is contrary to your conscience
then you better beware if somebody is
not of the people what people people of
the book right correct and people of the
law part of the little children you have
to be like a little child numbers 23
verse 28 and by like brought Balaam unto
the top of pior
that look us towards yeshimon
such nice names in the Bible I love
these names
so PR means Gap
yes
and there was a deity there was worship
there they sacrificed children to him
even
and jechimon means desolation desolation
so when balak brought Balaam onto the
top of Pierre
that look us towards yeshimon it
literally means there's a gap and you're
looking towards desolation a little bit
like
our backdrop over here this was taken in
the film yes
which is a which is a desert-like area
you can see it desolation yeah it's it's
beautiful but it shows you it's it's
rugged like you do it's like the Narrow
Path exactly
all right and there were three attempts
to curse Israel
so three angles of attack we said there
are only three false religions yes so
maybe we can pick up three angles of
attack and see how they work and how
they operate
so in the first article Balaam failed to
curse Israel
in the second article
Balaam blessed Israel
by now balak's Wheels were coming also
and in the third Oracle he actually
cursed baylech
imagine you're getting somebody to do a
job for you and then eventually ends up
this way
so his final Oracle
because there was another one is not an
attempt to curse them but a prophecy
concerning the last days and we that's
why we also did that study to show this
is the Christian era yeah we're talking
about little children this is the last
days exactly little and it's referring
to Little Children referring to little
children all right so you have to
believe what God Said
and if God said it he meant it and then
you do it
because like we've seen if you just
believe it you have two legs you have to
do it as well not enough
so let's look at the story balak summons
Balaam now we're not going to go into
the whole story of the donkey and all of
those how he came he was you know he was
such a stubborn man he wanted
filthy Luca
but uh
God said to them okay you can go but you
will say only what I say
Numbers 22 verse 1 and the children of
Israel set forward and pitched in the
plane of Moab on this side Jordan by
Jericho
and balak the son of Zippo saw all that
Israel had done to the amorites and Moab
was so afraid of the people because they
were many and Moab was distressed
because of the children of Israel
balaam's first article now one if we had
to choose is this a dragon art Oracle is
this a beast Oracle is this a false
prophet Oracle it has to fit into three
religious systems right obviously so
then there has to be certain criteria so
type has to meet anti-tun
and Balaam said unto balak
this is now the prophet telling balak
who is a waster a destroyer would we
have a parallel destroyer in the days
that we are living in yes Satan there
will be
built me here seven altars and prepare
me here seven oxen and seven Rams so
here is the sacrificial system similar
to that of Israel
yes also with sacrificing and everything
yes yes and they were sacrificing clean
animals
oxen and Rams
so if something looks right
doesn't mean that it is right right
that's true okay
and balak did his bail him had spoken
and balak and Balaam offered on every
altar a Bullock and a ram so here the
two of them the two systems are working
together there's something wrong there
yes
if you see the prophet
working together at a sacrificial
service with the pagans
who are not serving the true God
then you better be scared of them
true so when you see someone who says he
is religious and he is a follower of
Christ
and he is proclaiming in the Name of
Christ but he's standing next to and
participating at the Pagan altar
you better be scared of him
and not mingle or you better be scared
of him that should be a sign stay away
right of course yes you must run you
must run
so they were offering together
so that is an ecumenical altar if two
systems offer sacrifices together
can't be you can't mix truth and error
you can't mix paganism and True Religion
didn't we see that we saw that so that's
a clue
that's a clue and Balaam said unto balak
stand by thy burnt offering and I will
go for adventure the Lord will come to
meet me and whatsoever he showeth me I
will tell thee and he went to a high
place
now what did they do in the high places
they sacrificed right but to idle Gods
Idol Gods he went to a high place if you
go to a high place
then you better watch it
so if somebody says to me I'm going to
worship on Carmel where there is a
Baha'i Temple I would be
reticent to say the least right
okay and God met Balaam so God made sure
that there was no other influence he was
going to give the right message to
Balaam
and he said unto him I have prepared
seven altars and I have offered upon
every altar a Bullock and a ram do you
think God was impressed no I don't think
he was impressed at all all right when
jeroboa made a altar which was not in
accordance with God's wishes was God
impressed no so it might look to
everybody oh look how wonderful this guy
is he's actually worshiping God
God's not impressed no God was not
impressed and Jeremiah jeroboam's entire
lineage was wiped out right okay so God
was not impressed and the Lord put a
word in Balance mass and said return
unto balak and thus Thou shalt speak and
he returned unto him and lo he stood by
his birth sacrifice he and all the
princes of Moab so it's a very you know
spectacular yes event well it also lets
me think of in vain they worship me for
teaching the doctrines of men yes and
they took up his Parable and said
balak the king of Moab has brought me
from Aram out of the mountains of the
East saying come curse me Jacob and come
defy Israel
now when the Bible talks about the east
then that's actually
where Abraham came from
ER of the Chaldeans now haran
and all of those places those were were
the children of the East with but they
hadn't committed themselves to God
because even the father of Abraham he
was mingling paganism and and the truth
yes so that's error right yeah okay
so he came from the East so he was of of
that caliber well I can just mention
maybe that people can have a look at
your sermon Tara died in Iran okay
okay come and curse me Jacob and come
and defy Israel
and his answer is how shall I curse whom
God is Not cursed or how shall I defy
whom the Lord has not defied
for from the top of the Rocks I see him
and from the hills I Behold Him Lo the
people shall dwell alone and shall not
be reckoned amongst the Nations is that
an important point
I think it's one of the most important
points for Israel all right now that
must irritate the Nations that no
definitely if you want to be alone you
don't want to be subjected to their
religious norms and standards and you
don't want to be reckoned amongst the
nations in terms of worship you stand
out like a sore finger yes okay
but that's a very important Criterium
that though do God's people today want
to stand alone and not be reckoned with
the Nations no we're trying
so in other words God's people
say come out of her but we we mingling
and we we're in there all right who has
who has the truth if you have the law
and you have Jesus you have must have
both so who can count the dust of Jacob
and the number of the fourth parts of
Israel let me die the death of the
righteous and let my last end be like
his
and balak said unto Balaam what has thou
done unto me I took thee to curse mine
enemies and behold thou has blessed them
all together and he answered and said
must I not take heed to speak that which
the Lord has put in my mouth what would
be a correct attitude toward balam had
said
maybe repentance
he should have recognized that those are
God's people and he should have repented
but he's stubborn is like Pharaoh right
yeah yeah so he's going to give it a
second try so in this first episode
we have pure paganism
which is Dragon religion
and you have Balaam sacrificing with
them at the same altar Dragon religion
so beware of dragon religion Dragon
religion is demonic it is contrary to
what God is it's a very deceptive system
yes today we have equivalent spiritual
spiritualism
spiritualism is a dragon religion it's
anything where you talk with demon
deities
that's a dragon religion
so the new Edge movement yes is a dragon
religion okay so when you start mixing
things like you have
spiritual formation which makes
spiritism Christian and then you've got
spiritual yoga Christian Yoga all these
things remember in Babylon the dragon
the Beast and the false prophet are
together so there's a mingling of all of
these aspects but here it's very clear
that Balaam was sacrificing with them at
the same altar yeah that's Dragon
religion So Not only was Balaam shown
the history of the Hebrew people as a
nation but it beheld the increase and
prosperity of the true Israel of God to
the close of time
he saw the special favor of the most
high attending those who love and fear
him he saw them supported by his arm as
they enter the dark Valley of the shadow
of death
and he beheld them coming forth from
their graves crowned with glory honor
and immortality that's why he said let
my end be like their end
but of course his end wasn't like the
end as we were we will see
and about them coming forth from the
grave crowned with glory honor
immortality he saw the redeemed
rejoicing in the unfated glories of the
earth made new gazing upon the scenes he
exclaimed who can count the dust of
Jacob and the number of the fourth part
of Israel and as he saw the Crown of
Glory on every brow The Joy beaming from
their countenance he looked towards that
endless life of unallowed Happiness he
uttered the solemn prayer let me die the
death of the righteous and let my last
end be like his it's actually a
beautiful summary of what happened there
yeah yeah
so if Balaam had had a disposition to
accept the light that God had given he
would now have made through his words he
would at once have severed all
connections with Moab
so if you don't sever at once if you
find out that something is wrong
that's a very serious pointer right
exactly you're gonna get into trouble he
would no longer have presumed upon the
mercy of God but would have returned to
him with deep repentance but Balaam
loved the wages of unrighteousness and
these he was determined to secure
so it's a very interesting but sad story
Bella could not even now relinquish his
purpose he decided that the imposing
spectacle presented by the vast
encampment of the Hebrews had so
intimidated Balaam that he dared not
practice his Divine Nation against them
so Martin was Balaam thus a diviner yes
yes so he was not a true prophet of God
because that is condemned in the word of
God exact divination but it's important
to know that God actually used him here
yes and the words that we can see coming
from him is actually from God but he
wasn't willing to change no
so the king determined to take the
prophet to some point to where only a
small part of the host might be seen if
Balaam could be induced to curse them in
detached parties
the whole Camp would soon be devoted to
destruction
but that's a very important point so he
couldn't curse them all
now when we talk about God's Remnant
Church
it's not all evil no
it is God's Remnant Church it is the
church militant
the wheat and the tears grow together
but he's very successful
in
cursing little detached parties so as
long as they stick together
in the truth yeah
they're safe if they wander off that
path
they are not safe if they go and stand
at an altar with paganism they're not
safe so let's just look at this so this
is now the second angle this is is now
approaching the second animal in in the
first one he saw the whole of Israel he
was blatantly apostate he sacrificed
together with pagans at the same altar
so let's look how it changes his tactic
in the second article
so let's say it is a beast tactic
now a beast tactic is one where you are
saved by your works
the Beast is one that negates the law
and says you are not saved by the
righteousness of Christ they imputed and
imparted righteousness you are saved by
your works
and balak said unto him come I pray thee
with me and to another place from whence
thou may see them so let's let's take
another angle
Thou shalt see but the utmost part of
them and shall not see them all and
curse me them from thence be very
careful
when one little group starts doing
things totally differently to others
that that is so important this is inside
of the church yes I'm talking about the
church God's Church what we have to
watch out for
we don't want to be so closely
associated with the Sabbath yes we don't
want to you know seem as though we're
legalists and put a lot of emphasis on
the law let's rather call ourselves
something else like a good deeds church
maybe we can help you know do some good
deeds on the Sabbath and thereby break
the Sabbath in the process let's not be
so different it's our hair down a little
bit yes
so I brought him into the fields of him
to the top of piska and built seven
altars and offered the Bullock and a ram
on every altar same thing slightly
different and he said to balak Stand
Here by the burnt offering while I meet
the Lord Yonder so he didn't partake
with the ritual there yes and he didn't
use Divine Nation we'll see what that is
in a moment
and the Lord met Balaam and put a word
in his mouth and said go again unto
balak and say thus
and when he came to him behold he stood
by his burnt offering and the princes of
Moab with him and balak said unto him
what has the Lord spoken
and he took up his Parable and said rise
up balak and hear hearken unto me thou
son of sippor
I have a question here why did God
permit this charade wasn't once enough
no because he wants all the angles to
play out and he wants to give a lesson
here a very important lesson that we
have to heed
he did it because he wanted to save Moab
too didn't he yeah oh for sure didn't he
want to save Pharaoh everybody he gave
him 10 chances now here we're we're
meeting not with pharah alone but with
religious systems
so is there another king and his princes
that have heard the message from God and
refuse to listen yes
how long have they been sitting in
ecumenical council with this Prince has
it changed no so obviously it's not
working no so there's a problem because
there's a lesson to be learned all right
so it's not working
so what about the little groups maybe
that can work maybe you know the little
Protestant groups maybe that'll work so
let's try another anchor they've been
sitting how long with them in these
circles the same same this is working no
no like you asked that one person when
they said yeah but we're there for
friendship and everything you said okay
so how many converted you said zero he
said how long were you there 17 years so
it's not working I'm doing your method's
not working sorry
all right so God is not a man that you
should lie neither the son of man that
he should repent
as he said and shall he not do it or has
he spoken and shall he not make it good
behold I have received commandment to
bless and yes blessed and I cannot
reverse it
he has not beheld iniquity in Jacob
neither has he seen perverseness in
Israel the Lord his God is with him and
the shout of a king
is among them who's that King Martin
Jesus
that's King Jesus I'm I'm always so
concerned when I read other translations
and I I see this beautiful
passage is gone yeah like change it
changed
a shout of the king is amongst them and
I have not beheld iniquity in Jacob what
is Iniquity it's transgression of the
law that's it so I have not beheld
transgression of the law and I haven't
seen any perverseness and there's a shot
of a king amongst them
God brought them out of Egypt he has as
it were the strength of a unicorn oh how
they love to mock the King James version
about the Unicorn right yeah
let's talk about the Unicorn a little
bit in a while definitely
so you know it's a wild oxnow it's no
longer a unicorn but unicorn has one
horn and I think an ox has two horns yes
that's a beautiful reason why it's put
in the Bible and if there is a king
amongst them and there's only one king
and they aren't two kings or ten Kings
then surely he have one horn one Kingdom
why should he be a wild ox and have two
horns yeah isn't it also but let me not
let me not digress yeah well can we also
just have a little uh there was one
little horn not two little horns yes so
there's either the true king or there is
the false king that's it and they both
have one horn
surely there is no enchantment against
Jacob neither is there any divination
against Israel according to this time it
shall be said of Jacob and of Israel
what has God wrote
so his divination didn't work we'll see
what they did behold the people shall
rise up as a great lion and lift himself
up as a Young Lion he shall not lie down
until he eat of the prey and drink the
blood of the slain
and balak said unto Balaam neither curse
them at all nor bless them at all what
you're doing he's now a little bit
what's going on here
he's really angry but he's not willing
to give up yet
saying all that the Lord speaketh that I
must do so
he has the strength of a unicorn there's
a king amongst them
so the king of Moab disheartened and
distressed exclaimed neither curse them
at all nor bless them at all yet the
faint hopes the lingered in his heart
and he determined to make another trial
he now conducted Balaam to mount pior
where was the temple devoted to the
licentious worship of Baal their God
here the same number of altars were
erected as before in the same number of
sacrifices were offered but Balaam went
not alone as at the other times to learn
God's will he made no pretense of
sorcery
but standing beside the altar he looked
abroad upon the tents of Israel again
the spirit of God rested upon him and
the Divine message came from his lips
so now he is not practicing sorcery no
he's not practicing Divine Nation so
it's not blatant it's not blatant this
is a very dangerous one he is acting
like a true Prophet actually now
infiltrating yes but he's doing it at
the behest of someone
that's a very important exactly
balaam's third article
the false prophet versus the true
prophet
and like you he's actually a false
prophet but God is using him like a true
Prophet yes uh isn't there a false
prophet in in Babylon as well yes okay
that's a very dangerous one especially
when he is separate and alone
and you don't really know that he's
actually doing the bidding of the little
horn I mean the little King that thinks
he is like Jesus right exactly all right
let's look at this third article and
balak said unto Balaam come I pray thee
and I will bring thee unto another place
let's try another angle of attack
per Advanced it will please God that
thou mayest curse me them from thence
and balik brought balaaman to the top of
pearl that looketh towards Jessamine
Wasteland yeah
and Balaam said unto balak built me here
seven altars and prepare me here seven
bulls and seven Rams so again it looks
like the true religion
it's the same sort of thing
had said and offered a Bullock and a ram
on every altar and when Balaam saw that
it pleased the lord to bless Israel
he went not as at other times to seek
enchantments so he knew he had to change
his tactics so the first two
times there were enchantments now there
were no enchantments
we have to watch out for that
any form of Hocus Pocus any form of
methodology that is practiced to bring
you around to their way of thinking
beware of it that's where spiritual
formation and all that stuff comes in be
very careful you see that the roots of
that is lying in paganism
so for instance if we take the ogre
that's Eastern mysticism yes you can't
practice one and say that you are
separating the spiritual from the other
because you can't really know
but he set his face towards the
Wilderness so let me sum that up in the
previous two attempts it must have used
enchantments right or religious
practices
that were based on Pagan rituals like
reading the will of the Gods in the
entrails of the animals for example
that's what they did today they will
read your future in a teacup yeah
if you go to or use the stars or use the
stars or whatever you know that's what
the presidents of the United States used
to do they used to
suffer these enchantments and Ronald
Reagan for example used astrology well I
think they're still
mostly used these days absolutely
and in the third attempt he listened to
the voice of God isn't this what
protestantism should do just listen to
The Voice be like a sir he wasn't
jumping around doing his thing and doing
funny things and things outside of the
Bible so should protestantism however
seek to curse those who are obedient to
God's commands
no do you think it could happen that
protestantism will curse those who are
obedient to God's commands definitely
after all God had said he has not beheld
iniquity in Jacob so they were keeping
the law that's it but
that's the part if that will start to
get a little bit more serious in the end
correct so if we go to Leviticus and we
want to know what is Iniquity and if a
soul sin and commit any of these things
which are forbidden to be done by the
Commandments of the Lord
though he wasted not yet he is guilty
and so bear his iniquity he did not
behold iniquity so he was keeping the
Commandments and he didn't sin and sin
is the transgression of the law it's
very simple it's not it's a little child
can know it a little child can know
what's going on
so the law of Truth was in his mouth
says Malachi and iniquity was not found
in his lips so there you have Hebrew
parallelism so if the law of God is in
your mouth then you have no iniquity
he wokeeth with me in peace and equity
and did not turn away from iniquity
so now let's have a look at the
interesting signs of a prophet no I
believe that this is very specifically
also there so that the remnant can take
cognizance exactly because this is a
parallel of what will happen at the end
so we have some features here of a true
Prophet yes which we can adhere to but
if it is in any way aligned to paganism
then we have to be aware of it that's it
surveillance lifted up his eyes and he
saw Israel abiding in his tents
according to their tribes and the spirit
of God Came Upon him
and he took up his Parable and said
Balaam the son of beard has said
and the man whose eyes are open has said
now he's prophesying right he's got the
features of a true Prophet be aware of
translations that aren't direct
translations you'll get none of this out
of the others they are totally
distorted thank you
so he eyes the Eyes Are Open The Prophet
when he prophesies under the unction of
God the eyes are open and he has said
which heard the words of God which saw
the vision of the almighty falling into
a trance is added
and the King James tells you that it's
added by writing it in cursive so you
can read it which saw the vision of the
almighty falling falling but having his
eyes open
not opened not opened because that could
be in a spiritual sense this is literal
I know when we go to the spirit of
Prophecy
When Alan White had Visions she followed
this exact system even even the falling
happens and there and there was no
breath in her no and the falling just
before it's actually they say as if
some invisible hand is laying you down
correct not the catcher
it's invisible there's no you you just
yeah see the person go down
how goodly are thy tents oh Jacob and I
tabernacalo Israel as the valleys are
they spread forth as Gardens by the
Riverside as the Trees of line aloes
which the Lord has planted and has cedar
trees behind beside the water he shall
pour the water out of his bucket and his
seed shall be in many Waters and his
King
shall be higher than a God and his
kingdom shall be exalted
so his King Israel's King is higher than
the king
the highest king of these nations and
the moral sites
so this is very interesting
and we need to take cognizance every
single word is loaded here it has so
much value obviously it's talking again
about Jesus that's the king that's the
king that's the king and he's higher
than any Earthly King and his kingdom
higher than any kingdom yes
so Balin prophesied that Israel's king
would be greater and more powerful than
our God this was the name given to the
kings of the amalekites were at this
time a very powerful Nation but Israel
if true to God would subdue all their
enemies the king of Israel was the son
of God and his throne was one day to be
established in the earth and his power
to be exalted above all Earthly kingdoms
so this kingdom was to
eventually be the only one that remained
and you're either part of that Kingdom
or you're not take your pick
numbers 24 verse 8 God brought him forth
out of Egypt he has as it were the
strength of a unicorn
he shall eat up the Nations his enemies
and shall break their bones and Pierce
them through with arrows it's talking
about the mighty conqueror Jesus Christ
Christ
so now people are totally confused
what's this unicorn doing in here so
we're back to the Unicorn all right
here's an article in creation uh today
and this comes from the webpage
creation.org the very first edition of
Noah Webster's Dictionary in 1828
lists unicorn with the following
definition
an animal with one horn the monosaurus
the name is often applied to the
rhinoceros notice that this definition
says absolutely nothing about a horse
or a horse-like animal or Greek
mythology or mythical or fictitious
creature this definition simply states
that this is a name that is often
applied to the Rhinoceros
it are present their understanding of a
rhinoceros is that of a two-horned
animal if we look up the word rhinoceros
in the same 1828 dictionary
it defines rhinoceros as a genus of
quadruped or of two species one of which
the unicorn has a single horn growing
almost erect from the nose
this animal when full grown is said to
be 12 feet in length
there's another species with two horns
the bicorners
they are natives of Asia and Africa so
when you read about unicorn in the Bible
don't immediately assume that it's
referring to a mythological creature now
the interesting thing is Martin
when you look at these creatures here's
the name the scientific name of of the
rhinoceros with the one horn
this is the Indian rhinoceros its name
is rhinoceros unicornus it even has it
in the specific name
so is the King James wrong again like
everybody wants to say or it is actually
spot on
well Martin that is the living one and
it doesn't have a very impressive horn
no but before that when they roamed
around this is the end of a long process
of adaptation definitely not Evolution
no Devolution what did they look like
probably in the days when this was
written
much different we spoke about Evolution
last time we showed what the animals
looked like earlier and that the human
beings were much larger Etc and that
they even looked like Angels still until
the time of Abraham and that they were
much larger than today so what did they
probably look like and what was
what were they referring to
well here's the Siberian unicorn which
walked the Earth with humans now that's
an impressive one
definitely so that's the unicornness
that's the Unicorn
and it has one horn
Christ's kingdom is is one Kingdom horn
is a kingdom there is only one kingdom
and there's only one king that's it and
it's a true one and there's a false one
exactly and he's a little he's a
little oh he's not gonna compete with
that one
all right so now let's continue our
story he couched he lay down as a lion
as a great lion who shall stir him up
blessed he that blesses thee and cursed
is he that curses thee
and Bella's anger was kindled against
Balaam and he smote his hands together
and balak said unto Balaam I called thee
to curse my enemies and behold thirst
altogether bless them these three times
you know Martin he smote his hands
together
it makes me think of the king of Babylon
about salsa yeah when that writing
appeared upon the world wasn't his hands
that smote together but his knees
smelled together
the anti-typical dialect's knees are
going to Smite together at some stage
so you can't curse him no he does what
is right but that was I was thinking uh
that one we did nothing for against the
truth but for the truth
but nevertheless out of the story We
glean there are three angles of attack
yes
and the safest angle is to take the
little group by little group infiltrate
little group by a little group and get
them to partake in paganism and that
will start the problems inside dressed
like truth okay
so he says therefore now flee thou to
thy Place get away
that's what he says to him I thought to
promote thee unto great honor but Lo the
Lord has kept thee back from honor
and Balaam said unto balax Baker not
also to thy Messengers which thou
sentest unto me saying if balak would
give me the house full of silver and
gold I cannot go beyond the Commandments
of the Lord to do either good or bad of
mine own mind but what the Lord says
that I will speak
and now behold I go unto my people come
therefore and I will advertise thee what
this people shall do to thy people in
the latter days so now he gets a vision
and he tells balak what's going to
happen to all the Pagan nations in the
world when Christ sets up his kingdom
when does Christ set up his kingdom when
Christ came the first time yes and he
said the kingdom of God has come near
unto you and people are pressing in
right so what will happen in the
Christian era the last
period in this Earth's history yeah and
it lasts two days because he gave two
days worth of money wages
and and if you believe in the cosmic
meat Martin
then two days wages were given to the
church to take care of the beaten ones
the little Wayward ones that have to be
picked up in the world yes that means
two thousand years and then there will
come the second coming
there will be a final battle of the
millennium
and then the end will come but what
happens in that last period of time when
Christianity Reigns so let
let's behold let's go to this people
come and I will show thee what this
people shall do to you during the
Christian era yeah
it's paraphrase it that way
so before returning to his people Balaam
uttered the most beautiful and Sublime
Prophecy of the world's Redeemer and the
final destruction of the enemies of God
I shall see him but not now I Shall
Behold Him but not nigh.
so balaam's final Oracle latter days
Christian era spiritual Israel and it's
going to be a prophecy
so let's read it and he took up his
Parable and said
Balaam the son of Bjorn has said and the
man whose eyes are open has said he has
said which heard the words of God and
knew the knowledge of the most high
which saw the vision of the almighty
falling but having his eyes open I shall
see him but not now I Shall Behold Him
but not night still for a while to come
there shall come a star out of Jacob
and a scepter shall arise out of Israel
that's the Messianic promise
and shall Smite the corners of Moab and
destroy all the children of ship
so he's going to absorb
many from those Nations
and Edom shall be a possession Seer also
shall be a position for his enemies and
Israel shall do valiantly
out of Jacob shall come he that shall
have dominion and shall destroy him that
remaineth of the city that's a
fascinating prophecy
so here is the prophecy of the Christian
era there's a great battle going on
and the battle is with Babylon with the
three components as we had here in type
so we will have it in anti-times
now Jewish commentators have always
stated that the city that is being
referred to over here is a reference to
Rome
isn't that interesting very interesting
so
so he shall destroy him that remaineth
of the city that will be the rim and
Babylon is also called the city yes now
Babylon has a king
yes there's a dragon there's a beast and
there's a false prophet so it's a false
Trinity that's it there is a the father
who is the dragon there is the Beast
that is the Son and there's the false
prophet that is the holy spirit so
modern manifestations of the spirit
once you find them largely under the
false prophet yeah
differently
the son he wants all power everybody has
to bow down to him do we see Kings
bowing down to him religious leaders
bowing down to him everybody everybody
you want to be associated with the beast
power no with a false prophet no with a
dragon no no but better beware exactly
and be careful because you can be sucked
in if you're not don't have your eyes
open yes now amalek was a descendant of
Esau
now it's very interesting when you go
into that who the equivalent would be
today Ishmael
and who who says that they belong to
Ishmael that the ishmaelites let's leave
it at that
and when he looked on amalek he took up
his Parable and said amalek was the
first of the Nations but his letter in
shall be that he perished forever
and he looked on the canines and took up
his Parable and said strong as thy
dwelling place and thou putest thy nest
in a rock
nevertheless the Canaanite will shall be
wasted until ashur shall carry thee away
captive so he's talking about Petra
where they were up there in the rocks
and made their nest in the rocks and
they were taken away captive and he took
up his Parable and said alas who shall
live when God does this
and ships shall come from the coast of
kitim and shall afflict assure and shall
afflict Eber and it also perished
forever
and Balaam rose up and went and returned
to his place and balak also went his way
so all the nations that we are referring
to here
will perish that's what the statue of
Daniel said right exactly the same the
stone the stone that comes loose
destroys everything everything is swept
away and all the remnants of these
nations and whatever their names are
today the only thing that will remain
are those that are in Christ that's it
and that are in harmony with his law
that's the only name as well those are
the true two aspects of the true
religion
so Balaam according to the scriptures
must have given a final piece of advice
to balik this is interesting
which would change the blessing into a
curse this advice entailed leading the
Israelites into transgression of God's
commands and we read about it in numbers
31 verse 16.
behold these cause the children of
Israel through the Council of Balaam
to commit trespass against the Lord in
the matter of peor
and there was a plague amongst the
congregation of the Lord
so beware of someone who tries to get
you to compromise on the law it's not so
important which day you keep it's not so
important whether you obey the other
commands the health laws and this law
and that law it's not so important it's
not so important that we keep ourselves
separate the people that is separate we
must mingle we must just preach love yes
so watch out for those things
so disappointed in his hopes of wealth
and promotion in disfavor with the King
and conscious that he had incurred the
displeasure of God Balaam returned from
his self-chosen mission after he had
reached his home the controlling powers
of the spirit of God left him and his
covetousness which had merely held in
check Prevail he was ready to resort to
any means to gain the reward promised by
balak knew that the prosperity of Israel
depended upon the obedience to God and
that there was no way to cause their
overthrow but by seducing them into sin
and he now decided to secure balak's
favor by advising the moabites of the
course to be pursued to bring a curse
upon Israel
immediately returned to the land of Moab
and laid his plans before the king so he
came back
now the Bible said that he gave counsel
yeah they must have come back so this is
biblical
the moabites themselves were convinced
that as long as Israel remained true to
God he would be their Shield the plan
proposed by Balaam was to separate them
from God by enticing them into idolatry
if they could be led to engage in
licentious worship of Baal and ashtera
their omnipotent protector would become
their enemy and they would soon fall
prey to the fierce warlike Nations
around them this plan was readily
accepted by the king and Balaam himself
remained to assist in carrying it into
effect
and he witnessed the success of his
diabolical scheme he saw the curse of
God visited upon his people and
thousands falling under his judgment but
the Divine judges judgment that punished
sin in Israel did not permit the
tempters to escape
so the fate of Balin was similar to that
of Judas
and their characters bear a marked
resemblance to each other both these men
tried to unite the service of God and
Mammon
exactly Balaam didn't want to let go of
that money he was and Judas didn't want
to let go of that money and met with
single failure Balaam acknowledged the
true God and professed to serve him
Judas believed in Jesus as the Messiah
and United with his followers but Bale
and hoped to make the service of Jehovah
the stepping stone to the acquirement of
riches and worldly honor there's someone
else that wanted that yes yes Simon
Magus Simon Magus and Simon Magus became
the sorcerer to Nero
and this is where false Christianity
began you wanted to buy the Holy Spirit
you cannot buy the Holy Spirit he wanted
the power without the obedience and you
see we were talking about the money it's
also to have to want worldly honor
that's also it's important to realize
that it's not just physical money it's
that greed which church is the richest
Church sits on the riches of the world
once all the kings to bow down to it
once all the honor but refuses obedience
to the Commodities isn't it Catholicism
that's it well the one with the other
one
not the unicorns
okay all right we don't have to read the
whole quote
but let's end with this last
line here the only safe course is to let
our prayers go forth daily from a
sincere heart as did David hold up my
goings and thy paths at my footsteps
Slipknot we dare not be enticed
what is this pale worship all about
because it's looks like the real thing
oh that's we've spoken about this the
whole time now but it is a a beast
worship because it's based on salvation
by works but then you also have this
false spirit this and so you've got this
whole mix of everything false at pair or
you have the whole catastrophe you have
the Babylonian conspiracy yeah there's
something to meet every need oh that's
so true we've always mentioned it you
see the Beast
as open arms because he can accept
anything you can accept those that are
willing to be saved in their sin
and those that are willing to be saved
by their works by the Lost John so let's
look at this and Israel Abode into Tim
and the people began to commit horde
them with the daughters of Moab let's
make that the typological story
with other churches yes because the
church is a woman in the Bible
and they called The People Under the
sacrifice of their gods and the people
did eat and bowed down to their gods
and Israel joined himself unto Baal peor
and the anger of the Lord was kindled
against Israel and the Lord said unto
Moses take all the heads of the people
and hang them up before the Lord against
the son that the fierce anger of the
Lord may be turned away from Israel
and Moses said unto the judges of Israel
slay ye everyone he's men that were
joined unto bald-pierd No Moses was
always willing to intercede
but here he said slay every man that was
joined to Bald pure so the meekest man
other than Jesus to ever walk the earth
yeah gives a direct
seems like a very harsh come on but
remember Martin this is the typology yes
this will be the consequence
if you are joined to ball peor
then this will be the consequence
so even our own people
that are dabbling in this shouldn't they
be warned of course you see some what
boggles my mind sometimes is that people
say oh but God does not how can he be a
loving God if he says he's going to
destroy you if you do not choose him but
you have actually a choice
the other one doesn't give you a choice
no
all right
now we're thinking typologically and
behold one of the children of Israel
came and brought
unto his brethren
a midianitish woman
now remember the midianites
were from the loins of Abraham
and the moabites were from lot yeah so
they were also related to Abraham so can
we say these are like sister churches
yes
so here comes
someone from a sister Church you're
opening your church
to
non-law keeping people to come and
preach isn't that bringing a midianitish
woman into the tents definitely
in the sight of Moses and in the sight
of the congregation of the children of
Israel who were weeping before the door
of the Tabernacle of the congregation
so we will have churches where
midianitish churches women and moabitish
ones will come in yeah and they will
sound so pleasing
in this case it was a literal woman with
a very short dress that enticed
the Israelites and how did they do it so
it would this whenever this comes in it
will be with smooth words tickling the
ears something that you oh something
that looks very desirable
and when Phineas the son of Elisa the
son of Aaron the priest saw it he rose
up from among the congregation and took
a javelin in his hand and he went after
the man of Israel into his tent and
thrust both of them through
the man of Israel and the woman through
her belly so the plague was stayed from
the children of Israel and those that
died in the plague were twenty and four
thousand what this is a terrible shaking
that will take place
this is a typological shaking and they
were committing adultery spiritual
adultery and the result of spiritual
adultery is death that's it now how did
they do it
and the Lord spoke unto Moses saying
Phineas the son of Elisa the son of
Aaron the priest has turned my wrath
away from the children of Israel while
he was zealous for my sake amongst them
and I consumed not the children of
Israel in my jealousy
so do we need phineas's yes
that will address the issue and say this
is spiritual idolatry this is wrong
this is adultery yes should we must we
have them yes yes otherwise the Wrath
would come upon the whole congregation
yes
wherefore say I behold I give unto him a
covenant of peace and he shall have it
and his seed after him even the Covenant
of an everlasting priesthood because he
was zealous for his God and made an
atonement for the children of Israel
so we need people that preach the
straight message and we need to stand
together in this
because various sections little portions
will be attacked by this methodology
exactly that angle will be used yes and
then God still gives us more information
and he says now the name of the
Israelite that was slain
even that was slain with the midianitis
woman was zimmering
the son of sailu a prince
of a chief house amongst the simianites
so these are people in high places these
are leaders in the church exactly so
this is not put in the Bible arbitrarily
no no no this is very important so don't
look at every leader and say well he's
the leader so surely I can follow his
example
and now let's read on and the name of
the midianitish woman that was slain was
Cosby the daughter of zul
it was head over a people and of a chief
house in Midian so again you have high
up people leaders taking part
and of course the meaning zimbri means
my music or musical
and Cosby means deceiver a liar Sliding
Away
so how will it be done Martin with music
yeah now many years ago I gave a series
of talks that was called
Total Transformation
well I dealt with this already but I
think people need to be reminded
that music is a snare it will be used as
a snare and didn't we just recently show
we showed it where music is a snare to
God's people a huge one I you know what
and what was the message of the singer
any day wasn't he a deceiver a liar
exactly so God doesn't care about which
day exactly so and what does that take
you away from the commandments so one of
your legs is gone and people that should
know better stands and cheer this on it
sounds like Israel at ball pure and the
Lord spoke unto Moses saying fix the
midianites and smite them
for they Vex you with their Wiles
wherewith they have beguiled you in the
matter of pure in the matter of Cosby
the daughter of the prince of Midian
their sister which was slain in the day
of the plague for pure's sake Martin
this is a very serious issue
and this is written for our admonition
doesn't the bible say that didn't Balaam
also prophesied that this will be for
the last days yes
so Balaam the false prophet paid the
price for his role in causing the
children of Israel to stumble when the
midianites were punished for the
enticement
and we read about the Numbers chapter 31
and the Lord spoke unto Moses saying
Avenge the children of Israel of the
midianites afterwards shalt thou be
gathered unto thy people and Moses spoke
unto the people saying arm some of
yourselves unto the war and let them go
against the midianites and Avenge the
Lord
of Midian
so the Lord has a controversy with these
churches that refuse to obey the law it
sounds very harsh what we are reading
here but we have to understand the
anti-type this is where it leads to this
is what when Jesus comes again
this is what will happen this is what
will happen
so the war against midianites and
remember that all the wars of Israel
were typological Wars
as the Lord commanded Moses and they
slew all the males
so here's a problem already because they
slew only the males yeah who was doing
the enticing the woman the women
and they slew the kings of Midian beside
the rest of them that were slain namely
evil
Reba five Kings of Midian Balaam also
the son of bear they slew with a sword
so he also died yeah so he didn't
get his prophecy to Die the death of
those that are in Christ because he
chose not to he had a choice after he
got that prophecy that he could be there
he made the choice no he wants the
riches
and the children of Israel took all the
women of Midian captives
but they just can't get over it they
can't see that there's something wrong
with these women they can't see that
there's something wrong with these
churches if they do not keep the law
then they are not in harmony with a word
and their little ones and took the
spoils of all their cattle and all their
flocks and all their goods and Moses was
Wrath with the officers of the host with
the captains of thousands and the
captains of the hundreds which came from
the battle these are the leaders yes
with them and he said unto them have you
saved all the women alive
well these calls the children of Israel
through the Council of Balaam to commit
trespass against the Lord in the matter
of pill so the false prophet Balaam
will bring people to align themselves
with churches that do not abide by the
law of God and they will be so
infatuated with them that they
they will think that God is unjust by
wiping them from the face of the Earth
but the fact of the matter is there will
be no disobedience in heaven finished
they cannot be
so what happened that balaam's
suggestion a grand festival in honor of
their gods was appointed by the king of
Moab and it was secretly arranged that
Balaam should induce the Israelites to
attend
this secrecy hmm
so if you see something done in secret
and you see God's people attending all
of these things at the behest of balak
the anti-typical balac
he was regarded by them as a prophet of
God and answered level difficulty in
accomplishing his purpose great numbers
of the people joined in witnessing the
festivities they ventured upon forbidden
ground and were entangled in the snare
of Satan
beguiled with music
that's a button these are important
lessons dancing do we see it coming into
our church we do where did we see it in
Jesus time yes
didn't we have the same we have
anti-typical uh John the Baptist the
head was cut off on what you've got a
lot of things that's the same that's
right and they are lured by the beauty
of he Heathen vestals they cast off
their fealty to Jehovah
the Heathen vestals were ladies that
were associated with temple worship
beware of these churches
as the united in mirth and feasting
Indulgence in wine be clouded their
senses and broke down the barriers of
self-control
for 40 years God had led them in the
desert and given them no wine and given
them no strong drink
so God's people should be without wine
and with and without strong drinks song
Drink and that is actually
the literal and the spiritual yes and
there was lewdness involved and they had
degrading rights because they sacrificed
upon Heathen altars and participated in
these degrading rights
and they always sacrificed to the Dead
as well
so they joined him themselves to Baal
peor when Moses was aroused to perceive
the evil the plots of the enemies had
been so successful that not only were
the Israelites participating in the
licentious worship at Mount peor but the
Heathen rights were coming to be
observed in the camp of Israel the age
leader was filled with indignation and
wrath of God was kindled
it came into the camp
can we expect it to come into our camp
it's already it's already there it's
already so isn't that another sign that
we're going home yes
so they didn't they had to be awakened
to the enormity of their sin and it took
a terrible pestilence to break out in
the camp shaking there was a shaking a
terrible shaking Satan well knows the
material with which he has to deal in
the human art he knows for his studied
with fiendish intensity for thousands of
years
the points most easily assailed in every
character and through successive
Generations he has wrought to overthrow
the strongest men princes in Israel by
the same temptations that were so
successful at Paul Pierre
all along through the edges they are
strewn wrecks of character that have
been stranded upon the rocks of central
Indulgence Martin
beware of sensual Indulgence
we still have that same problem today
and here it says something else they
joined themselves also into bow pure and
ate the sacrifices of the Dead
Psalms 106 verse 28 this is sacrifices
that had been offered to the Dead
it says so in Psalms 106 28 now Martin
here is the information out of the
horse's mouth in the Roman Catholic
Church the Holy Mass sacrifice for the
living and the dead
if you partake in this or you're not in
Bow pure for sure if you're invited
Jesuit priest into your church or you're
not joining yourself to bail pure they
cannot worship together
this is a Roman Catholic source is the
mass offered for the living more
powerful than after your death
sent Anselm and Pope Benedict the 15
said they are could you please comment
the mass has the same value of Christ's
personal mystery of which it is the
ritual representation
Christ is sacrificed again and again the
Bible says he sacrificed once for all
this is idolatry so the mass offered for
a person already in God's Grace has the
effect of offering a gift of increased
Grace which the person may willingly
receive in order to become more
christ-like that's paganism that's Beast
worship it's salvation by works you can
see this church has got all three in it
yes as an intercessory prayer a mass
offered for a person in a state of
actual mortal sin May yet Supply the
grace necessary for repentance even
though conversion is always a free
acceptance of the grace that is offered
so by going through the ritual you
actually add to it
so let's read something a little bit
more useful
in order for the blessing of God to rest
upon us we must not only hear the word
we must carry it out in our daily life
your eyes have seen what the Lord did
because of Baal pure
the Lord thy God has destroyed them from
amongst you but ye that did cleave unto
the Lord are alive every one of you unto
this day is that important for us and
are they it shows you if you stand for
the True Religion and you do what you're
supposed to and you have true faith that
is accompanied by the good works because
they can't be separated
behold I've taught you statutes and
judgments even as the Lord my God
commanded me that you should do so in
the land whether you go to possess it
keep therefore and do them for this is
your wisdom and your understanding in
the sight of the Nations which shall
hear all these statutes and say surely
this great nation is a wise and
understanding people
you may think that it shows great wisdom
to associate closely with worldlings
that you may receive their favor but we
cannot afford to do this the world will
discern the wisdom and the understanding
possessed by those who keep all God's
Commandments and will say surely this is
a wise and understanding people doesn't
Daniel say Martin none of the wicked
will understand yeah he does but the
wise will understand the wise will
understand what is wisdom digging the
Commandment that's it the Daniel stand
out yes
it is in this position that God has
always wanted us to stand
God says I'm a jealous God the close
relation of God to his people is
represented under the figure of marriage
idolatry being spiritual adultery the
displeasure of God against it is fitly
called jealousy
all false worship is spiritual adultery
the second precip which forbids false
worship is also a command to worship God
and him only so only serve the Lord
so Martin as a final word to God's
people today
the lessons that we should learn from
these typological stories are so
important
and we are in the midst of baalpure at
the moment that means we're going home
right this is the final Onslaught this
is it
1 Peter 2 verse 9 you are a chosen
generation a royal priesthood a holy
nation A peculiar people
that you should show forth the Praises
of him who has called you out of
Darkness Into His Marvelous Light
let us Covenant to do that this is a
serious thing
and maybe people should start thinking
of not taking it too lightly I think so
let's pray
Heavenly Father
we have come to the final events of this
Earth's history
it is time for serious introspection
many of us are trapped with midianitish
women moabitish women
we are dancing and singing
and eternities before us
let us take cognizance of what happened
to those women
to those princes
and to those false prophets
that were associated with that kind of
worship
help us to make right choices in the
time that we are living in Jesus name I
pray amen amen
[Music]
thank you